i'm kiki palmer and this is the wired
auto complete interview
mama's getting hot on the net
what's kiki palmer real name okay we're
starting out light
my real name is lauren a lot of people
think you know because my full name is
lauren keana palmer and they're like oh
that's where kiki from wrong i actually
hate when people credit kiana for kiki
because actually kiki should be credited
for kiana my sister had an imaginary
friend named kiki and that's how i got
the nickname and that's what informed my
full name lauren kiana palmer because my
mom thought i needed a name that sounded
like real chill so i'd get get a job and
then i ended up going by kiki palmer
anyway so that's a little funny what was
kiki palmer's first movie a lot of
people think was akila to be was
actually barbershop too i had like about
four lines i played queen latifah's
niece good times what did kiki palmer
win an emmy for i created the sketch
with this character named chelsea barbie
chelsea vive taylor it got really
popular on my instagram page and then i
ended up getting into a partnership with
facebook and this production company
called kids at play so we did that
character in like kind of you know an
snl style took the sketch and turned it
into a larger story which was turned up
with the tailors and we ended up getting
an emmy for it so that was pretty cool
okay what disney show was kiki palmer in
okay so here's the funny thing i did a
little company hopping back and forth
between disney and nickelodeon i said
who's cutting a check the movie that i
did with them was with corbin blue when
i was 12 and it was jump in little
double dutch vibes okay what is the kiki
palmer meme well this is a difficult
question because thanks to all my my
internet peeps they've made a couple of
them so you got the kiki palmer the gag
yes you got the uh uh uh oh i know what
ain't i know what ain't then you got um
you know i'm sorry i don't know who this
man is you know sorry to this man so
yeah thank you for making me a meme i'm
very touched by now they've got this new
one of me from my complex hot ones
interview and i'm just like
this one's got a little sweetness to it
and now that one's like they've taken
that one very edgy honey they've i can't
even tell you but they went dark with it
it just kills me
okay
is kiki palmer this could get scary
let's see is kiki palmer in nope i am in
nope
so excited about this movie is kiki
palmer from chicago so here's the thing
i'm from illinois i grew up in a small
suburb called robbins very midwestern
town i was born in harvey a lot of
people would be like oh you from harvey
no i was born in harvey raised in robins
mudville stand up town was just so poor
that for years they didn't have
sidewalks we were just walking in the
mud little fun fact but i used to say
chicago because don't nobody know where
robbins is so when i first moved to
california and people would be like oh
where's kiki you know where you from
like chicago because that's something
that people can remember now it's time
to rap robins let people know so is kiki
palmer in a sorority no i'm not a
sorority i have nothing against
sororities i used to want to be in a
sorority but i realize that it's a
little bit political and this can get a
little bit spooky oogie i don't know if
i could really roll with it you know i
might end up slapping the hell out of
one of my sisters so i don't know if
it's for me but much love to anybody
that's down with it kudos to you is kiki
palmer in the old navy commercial yes
yes
expecting someone
i gagged at that commercial it's just i
really love like the early 2000s late
90s when everything was a little bit
like inside itself it was like
everything was a little like that and so
i lived for doing that commercial
because i was very like
expecting someone oh maybe
you know and so i had so much fun with
that commercial and it's just old navy
always was doing those commercials i
remember as a kid like you know they did
with little kim like it was just so much
fun because of course i would be santa
claus coming down the damn chimney like
of course it would be your girl cakes is
kiki palmer a lot oh [ __ ] they thought i
was dead i remember the first time i got
killed on twitter y'all remember that
when twitter first was created they were
killing everybody it was like
so-and-so's days oh it's so sad
so oh
and that's crazy to laugh like that
because it's not you're sad somebody's
dead but it's just like i don't know why
twitter i think it's because twitter
people on twitter started realizing that
they could make anything trans and they
were just like so excited they could
make anything trend and why they like
wanted to try and kill him
it's crazy but i remember one time my
sister called me cry she was like
twitter told me you did you're dead
no i'm not dead
so yes kiki palmer is alive whoa thank
gosh
that was everyone
so now we just have kiki palmer how was
kiki palmer discovered somebody google
that wow okay mama's getting hot on the
net so geeky palm was discovered by a
lady named sharon davis on the south
side of chicago my mother was looking
for an agent for me found an agent in
this place called baker and raleigh i
don't even know what still exists i
remember we were trying to give me an
audition for barbershop too and i
couldn't get one because they were like
she's never acted before queen latifah
is going to be in chicago for a limited
amount of time you know we don't have
any time with you know new actors we
need a kid that knows what they're doing
my mom would not take no for an answer
right she's like my baby needs a chance
put me on film doing the lines and
singing weeks went by we just went by
and we didn't hear anything and the next
thing you know the casting director who
named sharon davis she was like i saw
her tape we'd love to see her have her
come down and i remember i auditioned in
front of like ice cube you know and
everything like that and sharon gave me
the part and i say she discovered me and
then i also say a man by the name of
ralph farquhar discovered me because
when i moved to california ralph
farquhar who created militia the parkers
the proud family he
under his disney channel deal brought me
in and filmed my first pilot which was
very unheard of for me to just come to
california and just meet somebody and do
a pilot for me but he believed in me so
i say sharon davis and ralph farquhar
who discovered me how old was kiki
palmer
in barber shop two in the last day of
filming i turned 10. and i will never
forget because it was my birthday and i
remember this is when i fell in love
with michael ealy child i looked up at
michael he's walking by and i was like
it was my birthday i turned i turned 10
and he picked me up he said you turned
10 and swung me around and i was like
i'm in love with michael
i loved michael ealey i still love
michael to this day huh first crush what
makeup does kiki plumber use okay kiki
palmer uses uh
what makeup does kiki palmer use um okay
kiki palmer uses jordana okay it's the
makeup artist because i don't know what
the hell makeup i use i'm so sorry i
think i used a bunch of couple things um
in my personal life let's just start
there i don't know what y'all seeing now
i have no control over this what y'all
seen is a makeup artist named jordana
who killed it but in my personal life i
don't even know if you're interested in
knowing what i use for those looks
because they don't they're not on this
level but they're pretty cool who does
kiki farmer look like
that means that people have been looking
at me and being like she look like
somebody and i know the person they're
gonna that they're hoping to find
which is who they've been telling me i
look like my entire life halle berry i'm
kidding
i look better no angela bassett
everybody always tells me i look like
angie bassett and i've always done an
impression of angela bassett like i do
too so there's one impression i do from
um uh american dream the michael jackson
story where she finds out that her
husband's been cheating on her and she
like answers the phone he hears him on
the other line talking to somebody
talking about joe joe was like cheating
on her and she's like he comes back and
sits out he's like hey baby and she's
like you will lie
and you will cheat
and i don't want you i don't want you i
don't want you no more and with angela
it's all in the lips it's all in the
lips and it's the same thing with what's
love got to do with it when she's
talking to her friend and her friend is
like not messing around with lauren
fishburne's character i turn her she's
not not dealing with him being abused
and she's like you ain't got to hit me
but watch and then angela bass is like
sorry guys
it's okay i'm sure that that's probably
what they were trying to like remember
when they must have searched that who is
kiki palmer in big mouth i love doing
this show big mouth it's so much fun so
my character is rochelle and she starts
out as a love bug but then she has some
complications to turn into a hate worm i
don't want to tell you too much about
the show but get into it there's a lot
of edge to it as well who did kiki
palmer play in hustlers and house was i
played mercedes who was one of the
strippers in the club that was helping
to you know unfortunately
drug these men and robbed them for all
their cash with jennifer lopez and i
really just loved hanging out with girls
i love working with jennifer lopez who
does kiki palmer play in human
resources this is funny because i just
told you guys so i play the same
character in big mouth as i do in human
resources which is kind of cool because
it's in an acting world it's kind of
like they gave me like a little
promotion they like what i did in big
mouth and so when they did human
resources they thought to like open up
my character storyline and bring her
into the human resources their next show
that uh they ended up doing with netflix
so i thought that was just like so cool
like because i love working with them
too and i'm glad that my character got
to grow in into their next property so
that's great kiki palmer as a kid also
you must been searching up pictures i'm
not gonna hold you i was cute i look
cute cat you got a little charisma so
hopefully they got some cool pictures
from images kiki palmer as a kid yeah
okay i'm not mad at it kiki palmer best
friend
you gonna find some people i don't rock
with no more so careful with this one it
ain't whoever you find it online i'm
gonna tell you that right now
so scratch that okay kiki palmer fun
facts
so you're probably gonna find out that
i'm a virgo cancer rising sagittarius
moon that's where the pizzazz comes in
you know from illinois started an
industry very young i don't love long
walks on the beach because i don't like
what sand gets in my booty crack i love
going to amusement parks it's a lot of
fun i'm more of a salty person sweet
than sweet don't have a sweet tooth
definitely have a salty tooth my
favorite food is like probably number
one sushi love japanese food very top of
the list used to be uh italian but the
carbs honey i turned 28 we holding back
okay kiki palmer that's songs i've gone
through some phases and music so i mean
we can go from here to there i mean i'll
top line some of my favorite songs of
mine number one would be i don't belong
to you it's one of my favorite songs of
mine i wrote it when i was uh 21 22 it
was me really just like trying to focus
on how to express coming into my own and
definitely shedding other people's
thoughts of me which as a child
entertainer can be quite a task honey
because everybody always tries to tell
you who you're going to be and want to
keep you and the identity they see for
you which is kind of sweet that they
care so much but it's also like honey i
don't belong to you so i love that song
um because that that's a part of me like
finding myself and stepping into my own
autonomy then i would say bottoms up
honey because bottoms up was a sleeper
hit when we was kids miss kiki p miss
kiki p was looking extra flossy and i
just love that you know i actually did
like a remake uh to bottoms up not too
long ago and i was just really fun to go
down memory lane and just be like you
know yes like let's see bottoms up as an
adult and get into that vibe kiki palmer
favorite things my favorite favorite
favorite favorite thing is like going to
the movies especially like experiential
movie experiences like for instance boat
cinema i love going like this you can
get on the boat in like a little lake in
california and you can watch movies i
love doing that also i love rooftop
cinema drive-in you can do anywhere it's
just a drive-in movie theater very
classic like i love walking and hanging
out in the mall man i love going to this
mall down the street i'm not going to
tell y'all where it said cause it's my
mom just walk around i get a little
panda express and then i go and dance
ddr till my damn hills fall off i'll
just be up in there sometimes the other
guys be taking up the damn ddr and i
gotta find another game in the arcade
man that's a popular game but i'll be
just dance dance revolutioning all the
way up and through that place and then i
also love sitting at home and just
watching tv oh my gosh i'm such a tv
girl i just love just sitting back
watching tv ordering door dash and just
living my life it's a blast
okay does kiki plumber this could get
crazy because what are they wondering if
i'm dozing i wonder what this is okay
does kiki palmer have tattoos so i've
got a bunch i got like pyramids on the
back of my neck and representation of
the kush empire the first civilization
very interested in that especially as a
you know you go through the identity
thing and you're like from 18 i mean
from all your life but like definitely
like 18 to like 22 i was like who am i
what does it mean to be black in america
what does it mean to be black in africa
what is the diaspora so i went through
that and i loved it i lived for
everything i learned and i'm continuing
to learn and then i have like a bunch of
just like little ones i have a goonies
one on my um foot with my siblings it
says goonies never say die because my
siblings and i we just always we love
that movie growing up steven spielberg
is awesome i got a big piece on my side
which is just flowers and stuff like you
know represent my femininity but i have
a lot i like tattoos i think they're
cool does kiki palmer have a twin man
let me tell you something my mama have a
twin my daddy have a twin and they had
twins it just wasn't me my brother and
sister they twins man uh i'm very
jealous of them because can you imagine
a world where we have two kiki bombers
kiki and tt whoa and by the way ever
since the metaverse got popping off
apparently i can have about 12 kikis so
be ready does kiki palmer wear glasses i
do oh my gosh
i wear glasses and now i've been walking
around lately wearing two glasses let me
tell y'all something for all my
spiritual heads out there that's always
looking for like a different meditation
vibe don't ever do the sun gazing honey
i did sun gazing and joshua tree and i
didn't sunburn my retina playing around
trying to beat gandhi and [ __ ] so be
careful with that sun the uvs and the
global warming you got to protect those
eyes because now i'm seeing double and
stuff my astigmatism is like going left
the doctor said he can't even promise me
at a hill so i just been praying because
damn so yeah my eyes been bad since i
was eight and everybody in my family
wear glasses so hopefully i didn't do
too much to mess it up pray for me well
all i can say is like this was a lot of
fun you know going down this uh google
memory lane with you guys at wired has
been just very enjoyable so i look
forward to the next time we get to do
this again and thanks for having me